in Hyde Park this week organizers at the
George Floyd protest had billed the
gathering as a socially distanced event
but his numbers swelled way beyond
expectations that aspiration quickly
evaporated and by the time protestors
were swarming out at the park and onto
the streets of central London most were
crammed together for health
professionals beware alarming scenes
images that have now prompted the health
secretary to make a direct appeal to
those planning to protest this weekend
his message don't the reason that it's
vital that people stick to the rules
this weekend is to protect themselves
and their family from this horrific
disease so please for the safety of your
loved ones do not attend large
gatherings including demonstrations of
more than six people
the government's former chief scientific
adviser is urging those determined to
march to at least try to maintain social
distancing we know that the Bahm
community are more likely to die
largely because many of them are living
in more deprived areas in in Britain and
the demonstrations that demonstrators
themselves I believe should demonstrate
but please wear masks please stay two
metres apart Scotland Yard's
Commissioner has already said she would
not expect her officers to start
enforcing lockdown laws at the protests
tensions were already high on Wednesday
with sporadic violence for police this
weekend will be about trying to adopt as
low-key approach as possible maybe just
maintaining the policing presence
without being too over interacting with
the people turning out ask them what
they're doing
the difficulty is just managing what
happens from there it's almost like
reacting so some fast move you know may
be spontaneous incidents
despite the anger and the understandable
desire to protest health professionals
warned that the coronavirus remains a
significant threat that it would just be
their lives protesters are risking but
many within the wider community mark
white Sky News